at differentiate e to the 5x with
respect to X so this is a bit of a
callback to some of those earlier
questions we were having a look at again
this is in the form e to the power of f
of X so my derivative of that or equal f
dash x times e to the f of X so in this
case the derivative of e to the 5x my f
dash in this case because f of X is 5x
up the top there because f of X is 5x
then f dash X is just 5 and then I get
left with E ^ f of X which in this case
is 5x simple question that's why it's
just the one mark now this one here is a
teensy bit more complicated I've got
here log base a of 2x squared so again
coming back to our reference sheet here
y equals Ln f of X that's the same as
log base a of f of X so I'm going to use
this result here I'm going to say that
this guy here I'm going to call that f
of X so dy on DX will equal F dash X on
f of X that's what I got from the
reference sheet so if f of X is 2x
squared if I differentiate that I'm
getting 4x divide that by 2x squared and
there's just a teeny bit of canceling
that happens that 2 cancels leaving two
on the top this X will cancel with one
of the X's on the bottom and that gives
me my results what looks to me like 2
over X now just like in the previous
question that we had a look at or not
the previous but the previous previous
question we saw with the logs I can
break this log function apart into two
pieces as well so let's just have a look
at how to do this another way if I say y
equals log natural log of 2x squared
we saw the 4 when I had something
divided inside the log it becomes log
something takeaway log something this
time I don't have division I've got
multiplication so that means I convert
this into log of something plus log of
something else
so what what's a helpful way to break
this apart well
we say I'm gonna break it into log 2
plus log of x squared you can see
there's two and there's the x squared
which combined to make the 2x squared in
the initial working so now I've got a
simple if statement for y I'm now going
to differentiate that dy on DX log two
this is just a number so it's a constant
when I differentiate it I just get zero
so I'll just write zero and then I'm
gonna repeat this same process that I
did with the F dash on F before in this
case f of X is x squared so it's
derivative f dash will be 2x divided by
x squared and so I get 2 over X just
like I did before so happy times its
have a look apart see what's the
derivative of e to the 3x plus 4 on X
cubed so is a quotient here and we have
to deal with it using the quotient rule
so I'm going to call this guy you and
this guy V so if I write u equals e to
the 3x plus 4 then what that tells me is
that the derivative of U or you - is
going to be equal to 3 e to the 3x and
that plus 4 differentiates and
disappears if V is equal to X cubed then
that tells me that it's derivative V
dash is equal to 3x squared and these
four pieces here u v u - and V - they're
what I'm being mean what I use to
assemble my quotient rule now the
question rule is on the reference sheet
just like we looked at before I'm here
it is oops y equals u over V and you can
see that quoting of the question all
over there on the right hand side I
think that's actually quite complicated
even though it's technically accurate
way to write the quotient rule so my
preferred way of writing the quotient
rule dy on DX is to use this u - V -
notation so if I just take the same
question rule that you saw on the
reference sheet it converts to V u - - u
V - on V squared which my teachers used
to call a wolf so very easy to remember
so now
just need to quote all of the bits and
pieces put together the jigsaw from what
I got before so let's have a go
v is X cubed u - is going to be 3 e to
the 3x takeaway you which I think we
said was e to the 3x + 4 x v - which is
3x squared all of that is divided that's
better
by V squared since V is X cubed I'm
gonna write that as X cubed squared ok
we'll come back to that in a second I
need some more space so I'm gonna sneak
over here on the right hand side I can
do a teeny bit of simplification here
for instance I noticed on the top of my
fraction on my numerator I've got an X
cubed and I've got a an x squared over
here so there's a common factor at least
of x squared so I'm gonna write that out
the front fact I'm gonna leave myself a
teeny bit of space because that's not
the only common factor that you can see
on the top there's also a 3 here and a 3
here so I can take out 3x squared from
both of the terms in the numerator when
I do that for the left hand function I'm
gonna be left with let's write a bracket
here I took out x squared so X cubed
divided by x squared leaves me with an X
I've already factored out that 3 and
then I get left with this e to the 3x
that you can see here so e to the 3x
there's the left hand term and then I
have a look at the next part and if you
have a look closely
I've actually factored out everything
from that 3x squared it's something I
don't need to worry about anymore so I
just get left with the minus e to the 3x
watch out for that minus sign because it
then attaches or I should say
distributes this is the distributive law
if you think back to your 7 to that + 4
so minus 4 is what we end up with then
I'm dividing + X cubed all squared is
going to be X to the power of 3 times 2
so it's X to the power of 6
this means I can simplify a little bit
further so you can see that I get
I can do some canceling here let's
choose a color here x squared there and
there's an X to the six on my
denominator so what that means is I can
cancel out two x's you know X and then X
gives me x squared so that gives me the
three still on the top nothing inside my
brackets is a like term so I'll just
write it as it was before
three X minus 4 on the denominator
because I've divided through by x
squared that leaves me with X to the
four and I'm finished okay let's have a
look at Part D differentiate y equals
three close to the 4x all right so let's
have a look at this as we go you can see
that that column our 4x remember it's
shorthand for cause X to the power of 4
so we're gonna use the chain rule here
when I find the derivative for starters
I'm just going to put that three to one
side when you have a constant
coefficient like this you can kind of
just ignore it briefly write it down and
then it just doesn't really affect the
rest of the derivative now I'm going to
do the COS X to the power of 4 if I deal
with the inside derivative the inside
functions cos x there it is right there
so my inside derivative will be minus so
a negative sine X like so and then I
deal with the outside function it's
something to the power of 4 so I know
that when you have something to the
power of 4 you bring the index down and
then you reduce the index by 1 so
there's my differentiation and I'm just
going to now tidy it up a little bit I
can see that I've got in terms of
constants I've got a 3 a negative 1 and
a 4 so they combine into negative 12 and
then I've got sine x cos x or cubed
which I can write as cos cubed X that's
the derivative